اربع مباريات جرت يوم امس في الجوله
الثالثه من دوري المجموعات لكاس العالم
لكن كل الاضواء كانت مسلطه على مباراه
واحده وعنوانها ايران تواجه الولايات
المتحده مباراه بعناوين كثيره المباراه
المسيسه مباراه الثار من خساره عمرها ربع
قرن ومباراه الحرب الرياضيه وفي كل
الاحوال هي مباراه مجالها اوسع من المربع
الاخضر وفي النتيجه الولايات المتحده
استطاعت بعد 24 عاما تستاره من ايران في
البطوله نفسها وغلبتها بهدف الوحيد اقصاها
خارج المنافسه ابناء العم سام تاهل الى
الدور المقبل فيما حزم الايرانيون
المغادره اللوحه بعد فقدانهم فرصه تاهل
للدوري المقبل وهكذا تلتقي السياسه
والرياضه في لحظات تاريخيه
[موسيقى]
مباريات رياضيه يكون مجالها اوسع من
المربع الاخضر متى تلتقي السياسه بالرياضه
وكيف تؤثر السياسه على اللعبه الاكثر
شعبيه في العالم
في الرياضه بشكل غير عادي المقوله اللي
بتتردد انه لا علاقه بين السياسه والرياضه
دايما كنا بنقولها في الميديا والمؤسسات
الرياضيه العالميه دائما ترددها بس
اسمحيلي ما ينفعش اقول التعبير ده الصبح
بس انا هقوله مقوله كذبه الرياضه والسياسه
تداخل بقى تم معنى الكلمه مباراه الامس
اكبر دليل مباراه لها ظل سياسي كبير خلينا
نقول 60 الى 70% من الناس اللي كانت
بتشاهد المباراه بالامس لا علاقه لهم
بالكره القدم هم رايحين نشوفوا كلمه ساوند
ايران مع امريكا
سياسيه مش كره قدم في تداخل غير عادي بين
السياسه والرياضه ويجب ان نعترف به
محمد شفنا كثير صور شفنا كثير مواقف لناس
يلبسون شارات تسليط الضوء على قضايا
سياسيه مجتمعيه شفنا حتى ايرانيات حاملين
صور لمهسا امينه اللي قتلها النظام
الايراني اليوم ما هو الخط الفاصل بين
المواقف السياسيه في الرياضه وبين انه
تسليط الضوء على قضايا سياسيه ومجتماعيه
انسانيه في هذا الكوكب في حدث رياضي مثل
كره كاس العالم
اجتماعي رياضي وليس حدث رياضي فقط
فبالتالي الاضواء كلها مسلطه على هذه
البقعه الان من لديه قضيه يبدا في التعبير
عنه انا بالنسبه لي بالنسبه لي اتمنى ان
تكون الرياضه بعيده بدرجه كبيره عن
السياسه بس لا احد يستطيع فصلهم لا احد
يستطيع ابدا فصل السياسه عن الرياضه ولكن
بالنسبه لمساله لان في جانب اخر لازم نفكر
فيه هذا المنتخب بيمثل منه
اوكي هذا المنتخب يمثل من يمثل الوطن في
النهايه بصرف النظر عن الاطراف المتسرعه
وبالمناسبه كل طرف من هذه الاطراف يحاول
جذب المنتخبين اليه وبالتالي اللاعب نفسه
تحت ضغط مش طبيعي يعني يعني اردد النشيد
الوطني لم يردد النشيد الوطني بعد سياسي
بعد متعلق باننا اسعد جمهوري تصنيف جمهوري
ينتمي لمن ففي النهايه اذا لم تكن الروح
ان هذا المنتخب يمثل الوطن بصرف النظر عن
اي تجابات وفي النهايه اذا لم يكن الهدف
اسعاد هذا الجمهور فالمساله بتكون صعبه
جدا ومتداخله بشكل لا يمكن فصله ابدا